ces parcs et des bas
[Applaudissements]
demain
le pire sniper de l'émission tout de
suite les nommés sont ces samson
[Musique]
jean michel maire pour sa vanne de
spécialistes de films points du
c'en est trop il peut se retirer
côté privé arrête sa carrière alors est
ce que va nous est-ce que tu n'as fois
c'est une valeur styger jean-michel me
savane de spéléologues est-ce que vous
avez une phobie bouhadjar des oiseaux
les plumes d'oiseaux ça veut dire
majorettes tu pourrais pas te mettre une
plume dans le cul par exemple et
jean-michel mai
pour sa vanne sur les clowns blancs j'ai
la terreur des clowns blancs ouais parce
qu'en plus je sais jamais si c'est des
clowns blancs qu'on a maquillé ou s'ils
sont vraiment des clowns blancs on
croyait bien des mecs les business nous
l'an oui j'ai toujours du mal à passer
en jeune quoi les chaussures ont du mal
à passer
ah non mais j'en passe moi ça c'est jean
michel maire
il est aussi gage
ces vérités ou 2e catégorie et on en
fera trois autres demain les shihri le
plus gros vent le peindre au vent les
nommés sont
[Rires]
[Musique]
michel mais % 345 émouvants de la part
de géraldine maillet alors visiblement
tuée en edge pour l'addiction mettait
aussi en edge pour la compréhension
voilà donc ces noms géraldine c'est non
absolument ça sera non toute la vie ah
oui toute la vie bon d'accord pérennité
[Musique]
maxime gainey qui pensait être le
meilleur ami de mathieu delormeau
cyril hanouna pour le vent magistrale
que lui ami patrick sébastien vert début
juin on va faire on va fêter les 20 ans
au sporting de monaco et ben et en plus
on me dira on a dit et pas ce 3 mars
pour le reste je sens
[Rires]
ces vérités les jeunes portois c'est
mérité c'est pas mérité les frottements
et shereni sévérité les chéris on va
aller on va faire une catégorie encore
est le moment le plus gênant notamment
le nc non regardez les doubles
[Musique]
maxime gainey qui explique le concept de
sa nouvelle émission en direct on me
retrouvais quoi des tours de magie mais
les plus abracadabrantesques qui soit
aujourd'hui dans l'état et dans
l'audiovisuel privé et ce qui est très
important c'est probable vraiment d'eads
et isabelle morini bosc qui kiffe grave
c'est tout nouveau bijou qu'est ce qui
se passe va mal et givre elle m'a
regardé ce qu'elle faisait la montre est
monté au genre des montres et gilles
verdez pour sa danse de la race rare
[Applaudissements]
m
oh
on va travailler tous les gagnants
l'événement bien sûr gilles verdez
luganais
merci
ces propos n est oublié qu'on regarde la
meilleure vague de la meilleure bande
apprendre plein de choses à faire les
chéris mais attention la meilleure vague
de la semaine les nommés sont
[Musique]
isabelle morini bosc pour son hommage
aux chevaliers du fiel
ces deux de bon jet de copines qui
regarde par la fenêtre il y en a une qui
rit à l'autre offs à mon mari rentre et
je vois qu'il ya un bouquet de fleurs là
la cata et l'autre pourquoi il va parce
qu'il va encore falloir maintenant
remerciements que j'écarte les gens me
dis pourquoi pas de base valérie bénaïm
pour une blague animalière comment est
ce qu'on appelle un chien qui n'a pas de
pattes un chat qui n'a pas de papiers ou
non la peine pas on va le chercher
[Rires]
julien combes et pour une blague belge
belge qui rendent chez lui à la fin de
la journée
savamment lanta journée s'est bien
passée à l'étude à écouter ces machins
trucs bizarres
quelqu'un a tapé à la porte il rien dire
comme il a rien dit je lui ai rien dit
il est rentré dans l'appartement comme
il n'a rien dit je lui ai rien dit il
est terré dans la chambre à coucher
comme il n'a toujours rien dit je n'ai
rien dit il a couché avec moi et comme
il rien n'est joué rien des mails est
reparti à marée basse est qu on saura
pas pourquoi il est venu
pour moi je suis là pour gagner et pour
le conseil de l'atp baisser ni sa peine
dans les arts
[Applaudissements]
la chérie vérité